قار عبري يثير الخلاف في حكومه تل ابيب
ومصر تغيث القطاع بمساعدات عاجله ونتنياهو
لم تسقطه الحرب لكن سيسقط الداخل العبري
واليمن يطلب معلومات من الدول العربيه حول
السفن العبريه في البحر الاحمر السياسيون
الاوكران ينتهون من معاركهم ضد موسكو
ليبدا معارك من نوع اخر بوتين يعلن سبب
عدم انسحاب روسيا من الامم المتحده
واليونسكو صحيفه امريكيه تاتي بالحل لواش
وكيف والاتحاد الاوروبي مستشار الامن
الامريكي تراكم الافكار حول اوكرانيا
يؤرقني ويمنعني من النوم وكب ترد سنضطر
للتراجع اذا
توقفتم خلاف عبري اشتد الخناق على القطاع
والضربات تاتي من كل مكان الشعب ينتظر
الامدادات من الخارج لتفيد وسائل الاعلام
بادخال السلطات المصريه ع شاحنات تحمل نحو
150 الف لتر من الوقود الى القطاع لتلبيه
الاحتياجات هذا وقد توجهت نحو 90 شاحنه
مساعدات الى القطاع من معبر رفح تحمل
ادويه واغذيه ومياها وتستعد 180 شاحنه
مساعدات اخرى على الجانب المصري من معبر
رفح للتوجه الى معبر العوجه لتفتيشها قبل
توجيهها الى القطاع هناك قال مسؤول عبري
ان حكومه الطوارئ وافقت بالاجماع على
ادخال ناقلتي ديزل يوميا الى القطاع في
خطوه اثارت انتقاد وزيري الامن القومي
والماليه باعتبارها هديه للعدو وتعكس
الضعف في المقابل قال رئيس مجلس الامن
القومي العبري سحي هنغبي ان تلبيب لن
توافق على وقف اطلاق النار د اطلاق سراح
جماعي للرهائن الذين احتجزتهم الفصائل
فيما اكد المتحدث باسم الجيش العبري دانيل
هكاري انهم مصممون على التقدم في جنوب
القطاع واي مكان توجد فيه الفصائل في
الداخل العبري اظهر استطلاع راي نشرته
صحيفه معاري في العبريه تراجع قوه حزب
اللكود الحاكم بزعمه نتنياهو الى 17 مقعدا
في الكنيست وان احزاب الائتلاف الحاكم
تفقد اغلبيتها النيابيه وقوتها لا تتعدى
42 مقعدا واضافت معريف ان قوه حزب الوزير
بمجلس الحرب بيني جانس تعظمت الى 42 مقعدا
مبينه ان الاحزاب التي تشكل المعارضه تحقق
اغلبيه نيابيه تتمثل ب 78 مقعدا في
الكنيسه من اصل 120 واظهر الاستطلاع ان
50% من العبريين يرون ان جانس افضل لرئاسه
الحكومه دوليا تبنى برلمان نرويج مقترحا
يطلب من الحكومه الاستعداد للاعتراف بدوله
فلسطينيه مستقل فيما اعرب مسؤول السياسه
الخارجيه للاتحاد الاوروبي جوزي بوريل عن
رفضه للتهجير القصري للمدنيين واعاده
احتلال تل ابيب للقطاع كما اكد بوريل على
ضروره ان تعود السلطه المحليه لحكم القطاع
والى اليمن حيث اقترح عضو المجلس السياسي
الاعلى التابع للحوثيين محمد علي الحوثي
على الدول العربيه المطله على البحر
الاحمر تبادل المعلومات بشان تواجد السفن
العبريه واضاف عيوننا مفتوحه للرصد الدائم
والبحث عن اي سفينه عبريه في البحر الاحمر
وباب المندب تحديدا وما يحاذي المياه
الاقليميه
اليمنيه اوكرانيا
وحيده لا مزيد من الافكار الامريكيه لا
هل يعني ذلك ان كيف صارت وحيده امام روسيا
ليجيب مستشار الامن القومي للرئيس
الامريكي جيك سوليفان في مقابله صحفيه ان
تراكم الافكار حول اوكرانيا في راسه يمنعه
من النوم ويزيد من حده الارق لديه واشار
سوليفان الى وجود امور اخرى تمنعه من
النوم من بينها الافكار المتعلقه بالوضع
في الشرق الاوسط والاحداث المحتمله غير
المتوقع فيما نقلت وكاله بلومبرج عن رئيس
نظام كيف زل نسكي قو ان القوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه ستضطر للتراجع اذا توقف الغرب
عن تقديم الدعم لبلاده ليخرج السياسي
الاوكراني سيرجي يداي ويقول ان المسؤولين
في اوكرانيا يعتقدون ان النزاع مع روسيا
قد انتهى ويسرقون اموال الميزانيه لتلبيه
احتياجاتهم الخاصه مضيفا ان اوكرانيا
تقاتل على جبهتين ضد روسيا وضد الفساد
داخل البلاد وخلص الى ان الواهم بان روسيا
سوف تنهار لم يعد منطقيا فيما دت صحيفه
فورن افيرز بان الولايات المتحده والاتحاد
الاوروبي بحاجه لبدء مفاوضات مع روسيا
بشان هدنه في اوكرانيا مضيفه ان كييف يجب
ان تدرك انه من الضروري التوقف عن محاوله
الاستيلاء على الاراضي والتركيز على
الحفاظ على الجزء المتبقي من البلاد
واستعاده السيطره عليه ميدانيا اعلنت
الدفاع الروسيه ان قواتها نفذت 4 ضربه
مكثفه باسلحه عاليه الدقه ومسيرات على
العدو مؤكده تبيد الجيش الاوكراني خسائر
تبلغ نحو
5115 عسكريا خلال اسبوع وذكرت الوزاره
الروسيه ان طيران البحريه الروسيه دمر
سبعه قوارب مسيره و قاربا واحدا عالي
السرعه من نوع ولرد مع مجموعه برمائيه من
القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه خلال يوم هنا
اكد الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين انه لا
يرى ضروره للانسحاب من اليونسكو والامم
المتحده مشيرا الى ان موسكو لديها اتصالات
مشاريع جيده وروسيا هي احد مؤسسي هاتين
المنظمتين من جانب اخر وبعد محاوله
الولايات المتحده تصويب علاقاتها مع الصين
صرح بوتين ان العلاقات بين روسيا
الاتحاديه والصين لم تصل قط الى مثل هذا
المستوى من التناغم وبمستوى عال من الثقه
وذلك في خطابه في الجلسه العامه لمنتدى
سان بترسبورغ الثقافي الدولي
[موسيقى]
التاسع
ا